i was on set filming  for lemonade  which is the most beautiful body of work  ever yeah 100 so i was on set and they  saw my boots and they were like oh my  gosh where did you get those boots  thinking i got them from styling but  they were my own personal and they're  like we need them for beyonce and i was  like  take my boots yep and i was like okay at  the end of the day like hey can i get my  boots back and they were like uh so for  continuity purposes we actually need  them for the rest of filming and i was  leaving that night so i was like okay  cool no problem they were just my  favorite boots but that's fine it's  beyonce and i walked into my trailer to  pack up my stuff and there were a brand  new pair of  way better boots so i'll take it you  know i got to give beyonce a favor  oh i'm glad that you can both walk in  each other's shoes literally oh yes i  never thought about it that way i like  that